my next guest agrees on that keep the
politics out and address the problem as
it
is uh trey mendez is his name he is the
mayor in brownsville texas mayor
thank you for joining us you've been
separately dealing with this other issue
of
testing migrants for covid19 and there
was some concern that a good many
had uh you know across the border better
than a hundred
testing positive for this how are things
now mayor
hey neil good afternoon um things are
pretty much holding steady
we're still seeing a positivity rate of
you know well below 10 percent
uh the numbers that came out a couple
weeks ago were right around 6.3 percent
and the city of brownsville felt it was
important to to get a good handle on
this and start testing people just
out of concerns for the public and
public health and and we've been doing
that now for a little bit over a month
i think we've had about 2 400 people
come in so far asylum seekers coming
into brownsville and
we've seen a little bit over 200 that
are positive so far
you know mayor we can talk about some
addicts whether it's a crisis whether
it's open or closed
whether this is getting worse or not but
it certainly seems looking at the
numbers mayor that it's escalated and
i'm wondering
whether you fear that
you know those of power do not
appreciate the magnitude of this or what
it could be
we already know of the plans right now
to put a lot of these migrant miners
uh in a california defense space
facility um that might not be enough
there might be other facilities we use
so how do you how do you see that
developing
sure um you know at this time neil
brownsville is actually
we're not seeing the same numbers that
some other border communities are
on a regular basis we're seeing about 70
to 100 people coming over that are
asylum seekers
we cleared out that migrant camp in
matamoto's they had about 700 people we
were seeing about
50 a day and i think we're still going
to see a few that were still in
mathematics about 50 a day so we're
going to probably be seeing about 100
a little bit over that per day but but i
do know that some of my fellow border
mayors
are seeing some higher numbers for us in
brownsville you know it's really not a
crisis
but i can see i can see some of the
concerns you know if we see the
positivity rates go up
and we see the numbers increase and and
we don't see um
you know any any sort of real effective
legislation in the next couple months
and i can see i can see the concern
definitely all right so this higher
positivity rate you're seeing through
this rapid testing
of those you are testing how many are
testing positive
um the rate right now neil we saw about
a six
six point three percent um you know
several several days ago we're seeing
about um i just did the numbers a little
bit ago we're seeing about maybe about
an eight percent
somewhere around there as of right now
those that are being tested
and um you know that's that's uh
less than other places and and certainly
less in the state of texas
but it's still a concern you know i mean
we just want to make sure that
that we can identify those that are that
are testing positive then we can
quarantine them and
at least give them the guidelines and
and try and uh and make sure that they
don't continue to travel
any other place all right it's my
strategy
uh mayor i know you have your work cut
out for you we appreciate you're taking
the time trey mendes the brownsville
texas mayor simply wants
both parties to get on the same page
deal with this and quit pointing fingers
at each other over this not an awful
idea